petaluma nova had worked for 27 years as
a nurse in the town of ratza north of
the bulgarian capital sofia she was
going to stay on the job until she
retired the region between the Balkan
Mountains and the danube river is one of
the poorest in the european union Pecha
and fellow nurse naudia cristela were
not able to feed their families on their
salary of about 300 euros a month then
they spotted an ABS for a German company
that promised good pay and they decided
to try their luck abroad I trusted them
because it was a German company and the
Germans are known for their integrity I
never expected any kind of problems now
we're going in more problem they'll be
on what convinced me was the offer of a
German course here in brazo we didn't
have to go to Sofia to learn the
language and within two months we were
supposed to go on to Germany and start
work that quite pulses Amin mouse the
German courses were intensive eight
hours a day for eight days in a row with
one day off Oprah gallon or not it was
just too much material in too little
time and I wasn't able to process it I
just couldn't take in that much in fact
I hardly learned anything at all or not
much
the german company that had hired the
two nurses had its Bulgarian branch
offices in this high-rise in Sofia a
former company recruiter reveals that
the idea was to push the nurses through
the German course as quickly as possible
and then send them a bill for fifteen
hundred euros and fees payable in
installments from their wages in Germany
sometime we could have deduced the
commercials of these part of my job was
to find 10 nurses per month and arranged
for them to attend the language course
zero mom take Nia is equal course many
Bulgarians start from here Sophia's bus
depot on their journey westward a large
number are unskilled workers who are
looking for jobs as hotel Busboys
couriers or construction workers over 1
million people have left the country
since the end of socialism all too often
they're bitterly disappointed only when
the two nurses arrived in Germany did
they begin to realize what they've
gotten into petaluma Nova was asked to
work as an intern without pay Pecha
Petrova's new boss fired her the very
first day saying she didn't speak German
well enough for the job this video was
recorded right afterward 50 GS time
watcher I'm crying and my coworkers are
trying to calm me down telling me we'll
go back to Bulgaria there was no work
for us there than yeah we asked the job
referral service for a comment but the
offices in Sofia are empty and the
German headquarters also don't respond
but Amir boga have ski of the fair
mobility project has seen a flood of
cases like this that going through
though the law that the people turned to
us because they were afraid to terminate
the contract vegan signed contracts with
penalty clauses that said they weren't
allowed to quit the job for one year or
they'd have to pay a penalty of several
thousand euros got some fatigue
anaphylactic otha for me a thousand the
oil Ferguson Petra Petrova did get out
of her contract now she's back in brats
ax working as a nurse but she'll still
be paying off the loan for a long time
to come